very unhappy that he didn't repeal and  replace Obamacare as you know he  campaigned on repealing in a place  replacing Obamacare for years and then  he got to a vote and he said thumbs down  and our country would have saved a  trillion dollars and we would have had  great health care so he campaigned he  told us hours before that he was going  to repeal and replace and then for some  reason I think I understand the reason  he end up going thumbs up and frankly  had we even known that I think we would  have gotten to vote because we could  have gotten somebody else so I did I  think that's disgraceful  plus there are other things I was never  a fan of John McCain and I never will be  thank you very much everything